you have a lot of people working
across the country very hard to educate
people
in each state about what they need to do
to register
how they need to vote it's really
important
and i thought it might be a nice treat
for some of these uh hard-working young
people but i thought it might be fun if
we surprised a couple of them
with a little zoom bomb and it might
lift their spirits
right now because we know they're
working so hard would you like to do
that that sounds like a great idea
like hopefully we after us we just have
like so many people
who don't stay silent silent when
they're like in the face of injustice
um when there is there are people in
power who are doing
rockets everybody excuse me i just
wanted to say hello
uh conan o'brien here and i just want i
know the hard work that you're doing
i mean i i'm really impressed with when
we all vote i
i wanted to pop in and just very quickly
thank you all
for all the work you're doing and we're
going to show this on my late night
program tonight
i wish you'd cleaned up some of you
would
have killed you to clean up i hope this
is okay i wanted to
say hello and if you're cool with it is
it okay i have a friend who just wanted
to say a quick high is that all right
let me just hold on a sec yeah here we
[Music]
[Applause]
go
oh my goodness
[Music]
what are you guys talking about changing
the world
this is obama i was telling them i wish
some of them had cleaned their rooms
your room is perfectly clean i'm looking
at
you you guys look like you're doing good
i know that this group is working really
hard on
on getting the vote out and doing so
much there's one woman here
who uh is about to get out of her car
and do stairs
uh our team's a little bit out of shape
from coven
being quarantined all this time so we
have a lot of stairs to make up
oh my god conan you need to do that
what are you talking about i mean what
makes you think i'm not in perfect
physical condition
mrs obama her hair is a little too
perfect
it's not
thank you very much i love that during
this incredibly
tense time in our in historic time in
our nation
we have the former first lady uh talking
to you guys who are out getting
working so hard to get the vote out and
the conversation has gone to my hair
i think absolutely ridiculous
and absurd mrs obama i know she feels
the same way i do that we're just really
grateful to you guys for doing so much
hard work
very impressive that you guys are
managing to stay so focused on getting
people
registered and to get them informed and
you're
you know doing your classes online and
staying
involved in your teams and running
stairs and
you know i mean it's just amazing but
it's
it's work that is so needed it is so
important for you guys to get your
generation
and your peers and your family members
focused on this election
the work that you're doing couldn't be
more important and i am so proud of you
and it's like when i see your faces that
makes me want to work harder because i
think you all deserve
leadership that reflects who you all are
and you guys are good and smart and kind
and open
and caring and you deserve leadership
that reflects that so
keep working hard please and we love you
so much
conan aren't these that you mean ah see
if you like conan and speechless
yeah i i i just i'm very impressed with
these kids again
i think some of the rooms could be
cleaner but i'm going to shut up about
it well thank you
all very very much and i i leave the
final sign off to mrs obama
oh you guys keep up great work um
study hard stay safe wear your masks i'm
going to be a mother eat your vegetables
and give your families my love and your
classmates tell them to vote vote vote
vote vote
vote okay let's have a cheer for mrs
obama
[Applause]